pour une soirée film d'horreur c'est top
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on va parler vidéo
aujourd'hui on va parler de projecteur
vidéo 4k
c'est un produit de chez viewsonic je
vous en parle parce que pour regarder
vos vidéos sur youtube
autant profiter d'une belle qualité vous
mettra grand écran on va réussir à voir
du sang 50 pouces en 4k eu hd s'il vous
plaît vous présente un l'un des derniers
produits de viewsonic c'est le px 747
quatre cas l'intérêt de ce
vidéoprojecteur c'est qu'il coûte déjà
moins de 1200 euros et pour un vidéo
projecteur 4k
on est extrêmement bien placé en tarif
il vous permet d'afficher 8,3 millions
de pixels il est compatible hd r vous
avez un processeur à l'intérieur qui
vous permet d'avoir des couleurs
beaucoup plus contrasté des teintes de
peau optimiser une résolution dingue et
ça vous permettra surtout d'avoir des
expériences familiales gaming film tout
ce que vous voulez complètement
incroyable alors ce qu'on va faire dans
cette vidéo c'est l'ouvrir on va
regarder comment fse vidéo projet puis
ensuite on allait le tester on va pas le
tester ici parce que ici j'ai pas
forcément le recul nécessaire que vous
emmener directement chez moi excusez moi
j'espère que c'est bien rangée pour
aller tester directement ce vidéo
proches et vous m'en direz des nouvelles
première chose à faire en eau pendant
vingt six
je suis un chirurgien du carton alors à
l'intérieur on va avoir tout d'abord un
guide de démarrage des piles pour la
télécommande
ça c'est cool on a tous les câbles
d'alimentation pour leur accorder ici la
télécommande est ensuite carrément le
monstre
il faire impressionnant il est massif je
vous présente ce vidéoprojecteur
viewsonic 4,4 du hd c'est quand même une
sacrée belle bête que nous a fait
viewsonic ici voici donc la vette ont
valu à tester d'abord on va faire un
petit tour un petit peu du côté des
connectiques voir les différents boutons
à quoi il s'est fait son point qu'aucun
fait son poids mais plutôt bien et je
trouve que d'un point de vue en tout cas
purement esthétique il est bien réussie
en terme de connectique à l'arrière vous
n'êtes pas mal de choses déjà ici vous
vous branchez votre alimentation
toute la partie audio entrées sorties de
quoi brancher un ordinateur vous avez
deux prises hdmi six mini usb vous avez
lu sv vous avez pas mal de choses c'est
très complet est ici ça nous reprend dlp
texas instruments super couleurs hdr
hdmi c'est plutôt cool sur côté vous
avez une grille de ventilation qui fait
pas marrer du tour à l'avant votre vidéo
proches joli petit logo avec ses jolies
tipiak on bat pareil ventilation son
côté et on revient tout de suite aux
canaux arrière sur le dessus vous avez
si votre bouton pour l'allumer tout
votre pavé tactile fournir le piloter et
ici vous avez deux molettes la première
boulette qui vous servira à faire le
focus et la deuxième pour venir zoom est
directement dans l'image
bien évidemment le vidéoprojecteur est
fourni avec sa télécommande
si elle devenir et les piles sont
également fournis avec la télécommande
formé de succès sans vos différentes
sources hdmi 1 hdmi 2 réglage de la
luminosité du contraste qui a pas mal de
choses côté pratique la prise en main
est bonne bon maintenant ce que je vous
propose d'aller tester ça directement
chez moi on va se poser on va jouer on
va se regarder un film
on va être tranquille et on va voir au
final ces résultats de ce
vidéoprojecteur de viewsonic est à la
hauteur
oui ou non je vous invite donc à la
maison pour dire tester les vidéos
proches
il est juste là le mur est juste là je
sais pas si vous vous rendez compte mais
c'est énorme
là je dois avoir un écran qui fait
beaucoup plus 150 pouces compliqué de
vous donner le nombre de pouces exact
tellement c'est énorme
là juste devant vous avez ma télé
samsung et croyez moi c'est déjà un
grand écran
mais à côté d'eux
maj qui est fait par le vidéoprojecteur
c'est complètement hallucinant je peux
pas vous dire quel est réellement la
taille de cet écran mais il est
complètement complètement gigantesque
lorsque je m'en rapproche voyez la
taille de ma main qui part du bas qui va
jusqu'en haut
c'est complètement énorme c'est pape est
donc de faire vos murs entiers un écran
à part entière pour visionner le contenu
que je veux je peux aussi bien vouloir
regarder une chaîne d'information
écouter de la musique peut vouloir
regarder un film
visionnez mes programmes préférés films
séries sur netflix ou autre et vous
pouvez regarder vos programmes préférés
sur youtube
l'idée du vidéoprojecteur si vous pouvez
vraiment l'utiliser pour en faire ce que
vous voulez il va venir remplacer votre
télé vous n'avez qu'à l'installer il ya
quasiment aucun réglage à faire vous
branchez votre box votre console votre
lecteur blu-ray quatre cas ce que vous
voulez et vous envoyer directement la
purée et c'est ça vraiment qui est
génial pour une soirée film d'horreur
c'est top
un conduit comme ce vidéoprojecteur
venir complètement changé votre
fonctionnement dans votre intérieur
voulu grand écran plus des espaces plus
de dynamique plus de confort de
visionnage que ce soit pour des films
des séries imaginer une coupe du monde
là dessus du sport du gaming c'est juste
incroyable et c'est vrai que ça change
franchement ça tranche avec ses écrans
même si déjà vous avez des grands écrans
plasma au led lcd ce que vous voulez
toutes les technologies qui existent qui
ont existé pour jamais remplacer la
taille de cet écran avec cette qualité
en 4k uhd et ça c'est vraiment bien
d'autant plus que vous êtes sur un
produit qui n'est vraiment pas cher on
est en dessous des 1200 euros alors 1200
euros c'est de l'argent
je vous invite à regarder le prix pour
un projecteur 4k uhd c'est beaucoup plus
cher
et là c'est vraiment le point fort de ce
projecteur de viewsonic en plus ce qui
est vraiment intéressant là dessus c'est
qu'il n'est pas du tout bruyant pour
coût pouvant profiter d'avoir un
visionnage de qualité avec un
vidéoprojecteur qui n'excède pas les 30
décibels
vous n'êtes donc pas embêtés par le
bruit votre confort de visionnage est là
et ça c'est vraiment bien les pme dites
pas que c'est petit piaf là vous font
pas craquer sont trop mignons
au final expérience est juste immersive
hyper agréable
effectivement il faut pas qu'ils aient
beaucoup de lumière extérieure donc pour
des ambiances le soir feutrée pour en
profiter ça sera juste excellent
d'ailleurs à ce sujet laissez moi j'ai
des choses à regarder à plus tard et
s'il vous intéresse je vous ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description
n'hésitez pas à me dire ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez vous déjà
chez vous un vidéoprojecteur est ce
qu'un vidéoprojecteur comme le viewsonic
4k usd pourrait vous intéresser vont
marquer tout ça directement en bas en
commentaire j'en profite également pour
vous dire que viewsonic a plein d'autres
vidéos projecteurs 4k
ce que je vous invite à faire sa liste à
qui vous voulez sur leur site pour
trouver votre bonheur je vous ai mis un
lien en bas dans la description comme ça
vous faire votre propre avis bon je vous
invite également à rester connectés
bien évidemment vous avez
on va parler de plein d'autres produits
tech il ya énormément de choses qui
arrivent il ya une grosse grosse grosse
actu plein d'événements plein de tests
plein de choses à voir tous les côtés
donc vous allez voir il ya plein de
surprises plein de nouveautés et sa
garde le suspense on en reparle d'ici
quelques jours
soyez ça je vous embrasse et à bientôt
ciao
[Musique]
en france